[Music]
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now behold the transformation ray
awesome but is this safe though let's
find out
huh is everything okay down here
hey drac what's up johnny oops
[Music]
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
dad you're human drag oh no
i have a total dad bod
[Music]
what's up
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've
literally never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this there
is a place
deep in the amazon only there can the
transformations
be reversed time to go
right stereo man
wow flying as a monster is so much
better right
nervous liar huh
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious
it's wondrous
it's burning my eyes
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever seriously
everybody relax just enjoy the view
ah please being a human is the worst
dancer
hotel transylvania transfer mania boy
that was fun
the only place to experience transfer
mania is in a movie theater october 1st
bye